[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
41e jour de guerre en ukraine après les
exactions de boudhha européens et
américains muscles les sanctions des
sanctions qui touchent le secteur
énergétique financiers les oligarques
mais aussi qu'en est il de la culture
russe faut-il la boycotter depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine de
nombreux artistes russes ont été
déprogrammés de concerts festivals ou
encore salles de spectacle le chef
d'orchestre valery guerguiev où la
soprano un attrait brenco ou encore pau
gan sokhiev sont mis à l'écart sur
différentes scènes internationales les
représentations du ballet du bolchoï
prévue cet été
au royal opéra house à londres ont été
annulés par ailleurs la russie a été
exclue du concours de l'eurovision dont
la finale doit se tenir en mai en italie
en ukraine un mouvement de cinéastes
appel au boycott total du cinéma russe
ce mouvement en menacent donc la russie
d'isolement culturelle alors faut-il
vraiment boycotter la culture russe
faut-il boycotter les artistes russes la
russe relève t-il du soft power de
vladimir poutine les artistes russes
doivent-ils s'engager contre la guerre
en ukraine on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
luba jurgenson bonsoir à vous vice
présidente de l' ong mémorial france
professeur de littérature russe à
l'université de la sorbonne vous êtes
également écrivaine estonienne d'origine
merci à d'être avec nous et bonsoir à
vous en face de vous et evgueni
galperine bonsoir vous êtes compositeur
français d'origine russe et ukrainienne
vous composez d'ailleurs beaucoup de
musiques de films de toute l'europe en
il faut le dire tout à fait bonsoir à
vous frédéric mitterrand est avec nous
bonsoir hauteur de 1938 l'oeil du
cyclone c'est chez oh éditions ça vient
de sortir donc on entre la couverture au
frédéric mitterrand bien sûr ancien
ministre de la culture entre 2009 et
2012 et amoureux des arts merci d'être
avec nous en face de vous il reina carpa
bonsoir écrivaine scénariste et
musicienne ukrainienne bienvenue
également dans ce débat alors je vais
revenir justement sur ce mouvement de
cinéaste en ukraine qui appelle à un
boycott total du cinéma russe philippe
eliane qu affirme même que la culture
est un champ de bataille on écoute
nous ne nous battons pas seulement pour
nos territoires pour nos vies nous nous
battons pour notre identité
est dans cette situation la culture est
aussi un champ de bataille c'est
pourquoi je lance un appel au boycott du
cinéma russe
toutes les élites culturelles ou
artistiques de chaque société porte une
responsabilité devant cette société
parce que la classe créative est
toujours une composante moral de
l'indignation d'une société
et l'élite culturelle russe ou du moins
les cinéastes russes n'ont pas seulement
échoué à être cette composante moral
mais en plus c'est avec leur soutien que
ce régime en russie a été construit et
ceux qui ne l'ont pas fait on a prouvé
par leur silence ce qui est en train de
se passer
on peut comparer ça à la responsabilité
collective de l'élite culturelle
allemande pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale à
dakar vous êtes une artiste ukrainienne
est ce qu'il faut boycotter
effectivement le cinéma russe est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec philippe
williams cos a déjà j'aimerais bien
évité le mot boycott j'aimerais bien
utilisé le mot mise en pause les
suspensions le retrait ce qu'il faut
vraiment boycotter ces sont les
événements organisés par le gouvernement
russe par les institutions russes donc
tous les événements qui sont différents
c'est direct ou en direct par les
oligarches liés au pouvoir et par le
gouvernement après pour d'autres choses
vraiment
il faut me mettre en pause parce que si
on voit ça il faut faire par la
solidarité du peuple ukrainien par le
deuil après que le monde a vu les cadres
de bcia je crois que c'est bien évident
pourquoi il faut mettre en pause la
projection des films voilà les
traductions de livres etc après la
guerre je veux dire parce que ça c'est
la mesure temporaire après la guerre
quand les réparations de serre ont payé
quand les criminels de guerre seront
jugés on va on va vraiment nous mettre
autour de tables de voilà on va on va
discuter je serai peut-être la première
qui va aller voir le film de yves
guenver avec qui vous travaillez qui
j'admire comme réalisateur mais là pour
ce moment il faut vraiment appliquer les
sanctions une chose qui ressemble à un
boycott à être bien ni galperine vous
êtes d'accord votre frère vous êtes
ukrainien et votre mère aux russes à
faire mon père était un comme j'étais
rue crillon il naquit et vers nous avons
vécu
tous les quatre avec mon frère aussi
acquis et maintenant quelques années
je pense que c'est que c'est très
difficile de parler d'une manière
éthique aujourd'hui de dollars un
général alors que tout le monde a vu les
mots cadre les lieux des photos il a
entendu les témoignages de soutien je
pense que c'était un choc pour le monde
entier
donc je pense qu'effectivement
je suis assez d'accord dans le sens où
vous parler d'eux
laly culture est aujourd'hui que ce soit
russe d'ailleurs ou pas je sais pas
essayé mais l'on parle des russes et la
balle aux mails a fait globalement c'est
très difficile de parler de la vie
culturelle aujourd'hui parce qu'il fait
on est totalement accaparé par ces
images là par rapport à la culture rue
je pense que
il ya deux cultures us il ya une culture
us et une culture qui a servi au pouvoir
depuis longtemps qui la critique d'une
culture qui sert la pop au monde il
c'est une culture qu'on ne voit pas du
tout ici en fait ces cultures qui
n'arrive jamais jusqu'à les scènes
européennes parce que en fait les
européens savent très bien faire la
différence entre la culture de
protestation ou la vraie culture russe
est celle de la profondeur ou celles qui
arrivent jusque aujourd'hui
jusqu'à l'europe c'est dans la grande
majorité la culture des gens qui
protestent contre poutine c'est dans la
grande majorité des gens qui se sont
toujours révélées contre ce pouvoir par
exemple le palais vous parlez des
cinéastes plutôt
fc réalisateur qui dont les deux
derniers films ont été arrêtés la
production de ce film a été arrêté parce
que les sujets déranger les pouvoirs
serebrennikov fera notre cinéaste russe
le réseauteur de leto a été assignée à
résidence pendant deux ans donc en fait
on vous fait une distinction il ya six
ans
c'est pas seulement moi je pense que les
français ou les européens on peut faire
cette distinction est ce que ça veut
dire qu'ils doivent prendre parti c'est
à dire ce qu'ils doivent dire clairement
qu'ils sont opposés à la guerre en
ukraine je pense que c'est pas seulement
du fait de prendre partie évidemment
mais je pense que j'ai fait c'est aussi
sur leurs actes parce que netrebko par
exemple que vous avez cités après partie
après avoir supporté le régime d'oublier
pendant très longtemps s'est pas exprimé
clairement
c'est totalement les retourner sa veste
plusieurs fois donc en fait il faut que
ce soit s'en sert par exemple je pense
que c'est tout simplement les gens qui
ont toujours par leur acte pourrait
qu'ils avaient contre le pouvoir qui
mérite lui le fait d'être compter dans
nos rangs et pas dans le rang de
l'opposition d'un cran après 2014 il
faut voir qu'il y de fer entre le régime
juste juste deux mots c'est fou d'amour
du film dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
la finale de films cdk cda propagande
russe sur le crâne le plus terrible des
mensonges de la propagande russe sur le
garçon que si fier
qui est évidemment incluse avait fumé
extrêmement critique
pour critiquer l'intervention russe en
crimée frédéric mitterrand est ce qu'il
faut boycotter la culture russe
j'entends tout ce qui se dit avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'attention et de
respect je pars d'un principe ce n'est
ni tchekhov ni tarkovski qui ont attaqué
l'ukraine c'est donc pour moi déjà un
point clé c'est à dire qu'il ya un
patrimoine de la culture russe que je ne
jette pas avec les bombes qui déferle
sur l'ukraine par ailleurs ce que dit m
kenny me semble très juste mais aussi
assez compliquée à appliquer c'est à
dire et c'était suite à des problèmes
que l'on a dans ce débat c'est en vérité
si on prend par exemple
quelqu'un comme guerguiev qui est à
l'égard des fins léman chef d'orchestre
proche du kremlin justement j'ai pas
tout à fait d'accord avec evgueni parce
que guerrière fait est venu en france en
angleterre en allemagne à de multiples
reprises il a été très bien reçue à
juste titre car nous étions dans une
période de paix et la matin il est
retourné en russie il n'en sortira pas
il a dû justement on lui a demandé
de se prononcer contre la guerre
alors est-ce qui s'est prononcé contre
la guerre il s'est prononcé pour le
silence des piles est parti en robe
cible il est coincé en fait il pourrait
très bien
et pourrait très bien
refuser cette alternative est décidé de
s'installer en europe mais toute sa
carrière a été faite par poutine par son
talent propre bien sûr mais ensuite par
poutine ce que les patrons du théâtre
mariinsky il est patron du et vient
d'être récompensé d'une certaine manière
de son attitude en devenant le patron de
toute la musique russe puisqu'il a
hérité aussi du bolchoï
alors évidemment on ne peut pas inviter
guerrier que je connais personnellement
et pour qui j'ai de l'estimé j'ai même
présenter un jour un gala de charité
dont il était le chef d'orchestre et et
ça crée une relation entre nous donc
vous dites qu'il est piégé c'est pas un
vrai choix il est piégé mais c'est un
vrai choix aussi cette impression de
retomber sur la hauteur sur le problème
fürtwangler en allemagne est donc
finalement les les comparaisons avec la
période les périodes précédentes où les
périodes de despotisme
simples s'imposent fortement
voilà
c'est certain et c'est
certainement une une ligne de fracture
qu'on peut décider dessiner entre ceux
qui sont véritablement l'expression de
la culture russe officiel soutenu par
l'état et physiquement dans des périodes
comme cela devenait vraiment des
instruments de propagande et pour
lesquels évidemment on ne peut pas les
présenter chez nous pendant la période
que nous connaissons et je crains
malheureusement que la période soit plus
longue qu'on imagine je crois même
qu'elle soit très longue alors et puis
ceux qui ceux qui voient là qui
il ya par exemple il ya cet exemple je
vais très très rapide exemple de ce
lycée en vendait qui s'appelait socgen
ni jean et qui a décidé de débaptiser
folli follie rond peut-on faire des
choses pareilles alors justement et on
quand on voit qu'il ya tout de même deux
festivals du film russe en 1 à nantes
qui est un festival universitaire et un
autre à honfleur qui ont littéralement
annuler le festival c'est aussi
compréhensible
luba jurgenson vous vous êtes russe
d'origine lettone et vous vivez en
france depuis très longtemps et vous
avez signé une tribune dans libération
vous appelez avec d'autres
universitaires accueillir les ukrainiens
mais aussi les russes les biélorusses
qui ont dû prendre le chemin de l'exil
dont vous condamner la guerre mais vous
soutenez les artistes russes qui rejette
la guerre on ne peut que saluer le
courage de ceux qui prennent des risques
énormes le risque d'être battu d'être
incarcéré pour protester contre la
guerre et alors que ils le font
uniquement parce que c'est la voix de
leur conscience personne ne les oblige à
le faire donc je trouve que ces artistes
là bien sûr il faut même si les
le danger qu'ils encourent est
infiniment moindres homme il malgré tout
que celui que vivent les ukrainiens il
faut les soutenir parce que c'est avec
ces artistes ces universitaires et ses
écrivains que nous aurons à travailler
demain sur pour une culture
partagée
avec l'ukraine est construite avec
l'ukraine donc il serait vraiment on
aurait tort absolument de de les rejeter
mais maintenant si on prend la culture
russe sur le temps long parce que la
culture russe et pas seulement les
artistes d'aujourd'hui comme le disait
frédéric mitterrand s'est aussi tchekhov
si on prend cet ensemble alors d'une
part on est dans une situation
paradoxale en fait parce que d'une part
il faut quand même pas se livrer
le le pouvoir russe que ce soit dans les
années 30 soit aujourd'hui c'est servi
aussi de tchékhov tolstoï dostoïevski
pour
l'accueil aurait eu les sa propagande
mais aussi une arme de propagande c'est
une arme pour créer des lieux dans
lesquels on procède à recrutement de
d'espions ou tout simplement dans lequel
les gens avides de culture le
consommateur
futures évolutions voilà son sont piégés
donc il y avait mais ça depuis déjà au
moins 2014 y avait des lieux à ne pas
fréquenter il y avait des subventions à
ne pas demander et à ne pas accepter
donc voilà il est clair qu'il faut
absolument boycotter tout ce qui vient
tout ce qui est officiel tout ce qui
tout ce qui est tant soit peu financés
par là dessus vous êtes tous d'accord
mais mais le problème devrait aller
définissent et voilà mais je voudrais
ajouter aussi qu'il faut tenir compte du
fait que malgré cela la culture russe et
c'est avant tout une culture
d'opposition pouvoir et que ce même
dostoïevski a passé quatre ans ban que
pouchkine a passé des années en exil que
de l'ulster a été excommuniée et il a
rompu avec l'église après inventant
avoir entendu un prêtre bénir la guerre
que mène d'alstom est mort dans un camp
que
voilà que vassili grossman c'est a vu
son manuscrit confisqué vassili grossman
qui était né à odessa mandelstam qui
était né à odessa voilà donc il faut
considérer aussi
la culture russe n'est pas homogène et
moi je suis contre l'ethnicisation de la
culture toutes les cultures sont des
cultures hybrides la culture russe a été
au contact avec un culture ukrainienne
qu'est ce qu'on fait de gogol qui est
ukrainien
voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces
écrivains juifs qui sont tous vraiment
tous est né en ukraine depuis dakar
paraît très très très compliqué donc
d'ailleurs médiapart y aura le matériel
de ma collègue rna cela minsk à qui
exactement elle le regarde l analyse de
ce chef qui dit le truc sur toile et à
dreuilhe hk voilà donc est-ce que je
suis l'être tremblant où je le droit
mais là vraiment donc là c'est la scène
où il observe la mitraille mans de
fouilles qui n'est pas armé donc là
c'est très intéressant j'aimerais bien
revenir le déchet le problème que la
culture était toujours instruments
instrumentalisés par le pouvoir russe
malheureusement c'était toujours servi
par le programme d'ailleurs il n'y a pas
beaucoup de beaucoup d'artistes qui sauf
qu'ils soient vraiment indépendant
peut-être plus tôt dans le milieu d'eux
des cinéastes documentaire mais là ils
comprennent très bien cette nécessité de
mettre en pause par exemple kirakosian
coq et j'admire beaucoup la réalisatrice
documentaliste elle a dit je suis
d'accord elle était d'accord de retirer
son film ait donné plus tôt la priorité
aux films aux crânien parce que le temps
est comme ça parce que certains resson
us will de gestes comme les festivals
d'ailleurs on est dans l'air et on est
100 plants ont été annulés si valve qui
annule qui est ok on comprend qu'ils
perdent de l'argent et le père peut-être
l'audience mais on a beaucoup de respect
pour cette action de solidarité parce
qu'en ce moment c'est très important
pour nous et je vais expliquer qu'elle
n'ait pas pu le mesurer mais elle a
voulu elle était d'accord pour le faire
moi j'ai fait j'ai l'impression que
nous on parle beaucoup de grands noms on
parle beaucoup de des grandes
célébrités avec des gens célèbres dans
la culture russe moi j'aimerais bien
revenir à un tout petit plus ce survol
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et sur l'immigration vise à vous en
avait parlé je suis issu d'une famille
d'émigrés on est arrivé en france à 90
l'union soviétique était à 32 éclaté il
y avait la fin de la guerre en
afghanistan et c'est vrai que j'aurais
été à fait j'aurais trouvé très
douloureux et injuste ici en arrivant en
france j'aurais été puni pour les
méfaits de mon gouvernement qu'on a fui
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la plus
parfaite naples pas de gens qui partent
c'est des artistes beaucoup d'artistes
part de l'union soviétique en
abandonnant tous les sens leur
appartement de russie bien sûr est le
credo si l'ukraine aussi justement je
voulais c'est intéressant je voudrais
comme ça c'est l'actrice shuppan camatte
aux banques une actrice russe très connu
tout le monde l'a vu dans goodbye lenin
je cite ce film qui a tout de même est
vraiment été beaucoup vu voilà en fait
voilà quelqu'un qui a justement choisi
de condamner la guerre et aujourd'hui
elle est obligée de quitter son pays on
va l'écouter
je n'étais pas en russie
j'étais en vacances quand la guerre a
commencé
je ne sais pas vraiment à quoi j'ai
pensé à ce moment son
au départ je pensais qu'il fallait
attendre
ensuite j'ai signé une pétition
je tenais contre la guerre
puis on m'a fait comprendre qu'un retour
en russie n'était pas possible
frédéric véron ça veut dire que c'est un
choix là noureev pendant la guerre
froide c'est ça que je vois je pense à
ceux qui se sont exilés je pense à leur
famille qu'ils laissent derrière eux et
qu'ils vont certainement subir des
vexations de toutes sortes ceux qui sont
ici bien sûr qu'il faut les soutenir et
bien sûr qu'il faut continuer à voir ce
qu'il nous présente c'est presque un
devoir pour les soutenir encore plus
s'ils ont pris un risque terrible ils
ont ils ont mis leur vie en accord avec
leur moral leurs carrières en accord
avec leur morale donc bien évidemment il
faut les soutenir et là je peux pas
vouloir
suspendre leur voix ou
boycottez je suis d'accord avec vous le
mot n'est pas n'est pas terrible c'est
pas possible au contraire il faut les
laisser s'exprimer comme ils le
souhaitent
je voudrais vous risquez juste toutes
les voix qui sont anti poutine mais qui
sont dispersés dans le monde je pense
que ces gens là doivent parler chaque
manifestation culturelle est un acte de
résistance je pense que c'est les gens
qui veulent résister par leur art
doivent parler un seul de mes autres
noms et prénoms mais simplement dire une
chose que
si la culture a toujours été à des
périodes différentes depuis le djia
risme même si la culture a toujours été
un une arme pour un pouvoir nettement
despotique
il faut dire que poutine a été
particulièrement habile dans la mesure
où il a beaucoup insisté sur sa
politique culturelle
les opéra et théâtre le cinéma 7 g et
donc
le fait que beaucoup de l'artiste se
retrouve piégée alors qu'ils sont pas
forcément poutinien au départ mais que
finalement
d'un film à l'autre d'une chose à
l'autre ils se sont retrouvés dans un
engrenage fait que maintenant bien
évidemment on ne peut pas présenter
leurs oeuvres ni les présenter eux-mêmes
mais il faut aussi pour l'avenir
comprendre que certains sont plus encore
victimes que complice ina car pas oui
oui le problème est que vraiment ils
recouvrent les crimes de guerre par les
grands mots comme pouchkine d'accord
alors vous parlez russe vous les épouses
qui on va vous libérer donc c'est ça le
narrateur c'est ça qui est non je ne dis
pas que c'est vous j'aime c'est moi qui
le dit d'ailleurs mais après on parle
beaucoup de soutien de des artistes
russes pourquoi on ne parle pas des
artistes ukrainiens juste quelques
exemples baladine la ballerine russe
olga smirnova elle est maintenant à
d'atg
nationale et ils m'ont fait c'était une
étoile du bolchoï un jeune du coup mais
leur chaudière a des griefs à partir de
russie à la mairie pour le dos de
l'opéra de kiev il est parti de cette
vie ils étaient tués pendant le
bombardement à côté de kiev après marina
obscène nico va qui vient avec un petit
carton noir elle est maintenant une
héroïne elie millions le suivent et
l'autre la journaliste ukrainien
alexandr akouchi nova elle été tué quand
elle essayait de dire la vérité aux tout
le monde entier personne ne parle d'elle
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire en fait
j'ai donné je voulais offrir con qu'on a
trop de pitié pour les pauvres artistes
russes et on n'a pas et on oublie alors
j'ai vraiment il ya olic sorte que vous
connaissez sans doute tout ce qui est
maintenant dans l'armée ukrainienne qui
qui qui protège les valeurs
démocratiques qui protège le cren qui
protège ses batteries donc ça veut dire
que les a nichées russie devrait
s'engager il devrait peut-être même je
lui dise que ce que je dis mais s'y sont
engagés
ils risquent leur vie donc on peut pas
comparer les enjeux de 200 ce moment de
demander à ceux qui perdent leur boulot
il ya ceux qui risquent de les d'accord
leur maison leur vie tout ce qu'ils
avaient aménagé leur boulot aux est
d'accord mais la question du débat
c'était faut-il pouvait frotter les
artistes russes non répond à la question
c'est comment on va peut-être perdre
aussi beaucoup de choses
vous la voyez pas un traître olga
oulianova c'était c'était très bien
c'était un bolchoï c'était un ami
qu'on voit c'est la journaliste
non non non je croyais avoir aussi que
le que la culture russes qui s'opposent
au pouvoir de poutine et la culture
ukrainienne ont le même ennemi donc je
crois que c'est important vous dites
d'ailleurs la clôture russe est une
culture européenne c'est ce que vous
dites dans les races se comblent culture
cugnaux ii et bien sûr comme la culture
chrétienne lui tout à fait mais
aujourd'hui avec on doit faire
distinction je reviens vers la question
de voir là des spéculations c'est pour
ça qu'on connait vite le mot boycott et
je reviens à notre volonté à volonté de
tous les ukrainiens revenir aux
discussions autour de tables rondes
quand tout sera fini donc là et quand
tout sera fini enfin moi je pense qu'on
a aussi quelque chose à tirer une à une
une leçon à tirer peut-être de
l'expérience de l'immigration justement
parce que le la culture russe s'est pas
seulement la culture de l'union
soviétique la russie c'est aussi une
culture de la diaspora qui est une forme
à la mine vraiment eu de sépulture au
bout se sont développées pendant parce
que ça à l'union soviétique à une très
une loge élite énorme où se sont
développées des maisons d'édition des
des revues des lieux de des lieux de
débat et ce terrain et je me dis
aujourd'hui
il faudrait qu'on ait y avait des revues
par exemple dans lesquels collaborait
des dissidents russes
venus en occident avec des dissidents
ukrainien qui d'ailleurs oeuvrait de
cancer
d'accord vous êtes c'est très douloureux
qu'est ce que cette douloureux vous avez
vu les cadres des boutades et ah bah oui
bien sûr on est très heureux on aime en
cela c'est qu'on dresse pour le moment
c'est pas possible vraiment
on va voir tout de même que vladimir
poutine lui comparé ce qu'il appelle la
can seul coacher à la culture de
l'annulation aux autodafés du troisième
reich donc on va écouter plénière
poutine
aujourd'hui il essaie d'annuler un pays
millénaires d'annuler notre peuple je
parle de la discrimination progressive
envers tout ce qui touche à la russie de
cette tendance qui se développe dans un
certain nombre d'états occidentaux ne
sont rien d un peu de sauce il affiche
on efface des affiches de concerts de
tchaïkovski chostakovitch armani nov
sont interdits les écrivains russes et
leur livre la dernière fois ce sont les
nazis en allemagne il y à près de 90 ans
qui ont mené une telle campagne de
destruction d'une culture indésirables
et le système guérini l'autre chose même
deux pour mieux on se souvient bien des
images des livres brûlés sur les places
publiques il est impossible d'imaginer
cela dans notre pays pauvres n'achètent
rien
que ça alimente aussi le discours de
propagande de manière poutine alors
voilà il ya quelques jours poutine avait
fait un discours
qui était dirigée dans sa grande partie
contre les résistants ce qui ce qui est
en russie essaie de résister à sa vision
du monde c'est qu'on parle de 30% de
russes qui sont pas d'accord la guerre
20% de rue qui sont pas d'accord avec la
guerre c'est très peu c'est comme un 20
millions de personnes 25 millions de
personnes donc c'est quand même une
partie importante de gens qui est qui
qui n'ont pas peur poutine salle énerve
énormément on voit que hill et son
discours très violent parce qu'enfin
départ de la cinquième colonne et parle
des gens qui ont des valeurs européennes
qui ne veulent pas se mettre à la vision
de du monde russes et de l'opposition
entre la russie et le monde occidental
qui que lui veut imposer donc on voit
que si ça m'énerve à ce point là c'est
que ces gens là jouent en septembre la
russie et que c'est vrai que si au saut
de tourner deux et j'ai entendu ce
discours souvent parce que je parle
beaucoup avec les ukrainiens j'ai des
amis de deux côtés et c'est un cauchemar
surtout pour les ukrainiens aussi en
deuxième partie proposée pour les russes
et a fait beaucoup de dire nous disent
mais est ce qu'ils savent qu résister ce
qu'on est ce qu'ils savent qu'on publie
des choses qu'ils savent quand deux là
parce que c'est pas pour qu'on les
caresse
c'est juste parce que ils ont ils ont
envie que ces actions là soient vus et
que c'est ça leur permet aussi de garder
leur honneur en fait de cette manière là
je voudrais qu'il y ait quelque chose de
très très bizarre entre autres choses
chez poutine dans sa relation avec le
nazisme
il est toute la journée en train de
parler des nazis l'asie n'a plus
vraiment il ya des fascistes en france
dernière
il était alors est ce que c'est parce
qu'il a passé 7 10 ans en allemagne de
l'est nous est-ce que non et d'un homme
attend déjà
est ce que c'est parce qu'il a c'est
très très disert cette relation c'est
une relation
ambigüe finalement il est il un
comportement très près c'est comme si
finalement ils les admirait comme étant
leurs rivales ou leurs concurrents c'est
très très bizarre et quand il dit que la
can c'est quand il dit qu'il a qu'un
seul calcium ce sont les autodafés du
troisième reich sa révérence tout de
suite la référence vous qui venez
d'écrire un livre sur 1938 est toujours
la référence c'est très très vite et
c'est alors que ça veut désosser très
inquiétant à moscou quand on à brûler le
livre de ce rock in
moscow si ce que vous dites est
facilement par le fait que en russie les
nazis c'est un peu le mal absolu ils
tirent sur nous
que ça il tire ce mot de son chapeau à
chaque fois qu'il veut
définir un ennemi donc évidemment tout
en installant un régime fasciste
lui-même il accuse les autres et puis ça
c'est vrai que c'est vrai mais ce qu'ils
n'utilisent pas également ce boycott
parce qu'en fait dans son discours il
utilise toujours quelques choses
et effectivement ils les andelys tome
de boycott irene a car parce que c'est
pas le danger justement ce boycott est
ce qu'il n'a pas d'hier et a un effet
boomerang qui fait que ça alimente
encore ce discours vient pas des revers
ma précision qui s'est pas là boycott
c'est la pause ces mises en poste comme
les sanctions voilà économique saas et
les sanctions que qu'on évite les
événements culturels liés à la russie
pour le moment voilà et comme dit
compris par exemple à zagreb il ay lui à
zagreb ils ont par exemple annulé un
concert de tchaïkovski bon est-ce que ça
fait partie pour vous du type de concert
effectivement qui doit être annulée oui
là pour le moment oui oui pour le moment
on met en pause tout après on reprend
donc là c'est quand quand les voilà
qu'on les coupables seront punis on va
donc même les compositions du 19e vous
fait pas de distinction est là pour le
voilà vos la culture c'est vraiment la
culture et politique aujourd'hui c'est
ça la réponse c'est ça le problème que
la culture est devenue politique et
l'uja
sous les fleurs de beauté on passe
encore donc là on essaye d'embellir les
choses c'est
le détournement de l'usagé le
détournement de la culture qui sont
politiques mais c'est pas la culture
elle-même aucun concert de texte ce qui
par exemple annulé avec la grève si
c'est un orchestre qui arrive
directement de gomme ou de russie on
annule voilà parce que c'est un
organisme quasiment d'état et si ce
n'est pas un orchestre russe c'est juste
le compositeur sont des débuts si siens
croate puisqu'on parle de zagreb rouge
passion alors on n'interdit pas moriba
jorgensen musiciens déserté les rues
j'aimerais aussi encore une fois revenir
sur ce pan de la culture hall ce qui
dérange profondément le pouvoir et en
l'occurrence
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
témoignages sur les violences
stalinienne et c'est une un pan de la
culture que l'on a vu marginalisés
progressivement au cours des dernières
années
en même temps qu'eux étaient a commencé
à être persécutés l'association mémorial
qui travaille précisément à la fois sur
les sur les violences du passé sur la
mémoire du passé et sur les droits
humains et voilà et est donc tour pour
commencer cette guerre il fallait aussi
détruire cette partie de la société
civile
mémorial a été dissoute le 29 le 29
décembre et comme comme un dit
constantin sing off un philosophe
ukrainien récemment il a dit j'ai
compris le 29 décembre qui aurait une
guerre parce que mémorial a été
interdite mais c'est l'association
redonner un peu de contacts mémorial et
l'association qui c'est l'arrêt de serre
des ans est une c'est une association
qui s'est créé au moment de la perse
troïka et qui s'est spécialisée dans la
restitution il a de la mémoire des
violences tony nième du goulag et il
était dissoute et l'a été dans tout le
29 elle est persécutée et des chais et
et 18 ans il y est ce qui est fascinant
c'est un peu ce récit est raconté dans
mon livre aussi c'est le les démocraties
ont toujours un temps de retard c'est à
dire qu'au fond là au fond la guerre en
ukraine a commencé il ya dix ans aie aie
aie aie et la succession de crime
auquel s'est livré poutine d'assassinât
elles n'ont pas suscité de réaction
aussi violente qu'elle serait du pur ya
toujours une sorte de retard pour parler
familièrement retard à l'allumage et
démocratie qui aurait dû en fait
intervenir déjà plus tôt pour en revenir
au sujet sur le boycott justement la
culture gagné galperine pour rebondir
seulement sur ce que vous venez de dire
irena car pas la rue c'est ce que c'est
du soft power au service de vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui dans un contexte de
conflit en ukraine en fait moi je repère
les artistes ukrainiens ont peur la
seule raison et je pense
qu ils ont peur que poutine se sert de
la culture russe pour camoufler et
envoyer les européens l'occident en
disant oui c'est vrai on a fait des
bêtises mais vous regardez on a on à la
guerre et la paix on a chacun ce qu'il y
en a juste convictionnels tarkovski etc
moi je pense que c'est il ne faut pas
prendre les occidentaux pour des enfants
je suis entouré par plant de français et
pas seulement de français d'européens
qui savent parfaitement faire la
distinction entre le poutine la
démogagie la propagande qu'ils s'aiment
depuis des années et puis effectivement
dix ans et les artistes russes ou
ukrainiens ou la russie en tout cas
parce que c'est de ça qu'on parle
aujourd'hui ils ont totalement capables
de faire la distinction il sait pas
parce qu'il est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
artistes russes sont responsables aussi
de ce qui se passerait cette guerre dit
finalement irène un quart par mon geste
a une responsabilité morale qui fait que
effectivement les avait laissés de côté
est-ce que chalamov
de des goulags staliniens
chalamov au contraire nous nous explique
ce que l'état missionné
mais je dois mener après j'ai
l'impression que les artistes qui qui ne
se seront pas révélées qui ne sont pas
partis ne sont pas qu'ils sont restés
qu'ils sont silencieux ont
malheureusement je dois le dire une
responsabilité collective dans cette
guerre et dans ces situations qui vivent
eux mêmes les artistes qui résiste et
qui sont partis qui n'acceptent pas de
faire partie de ces sociétés je trouve
que ils ont payé le prix fort pour
justement ne pas avoir ses
responsabilités en mai est ce que le
choix parce qu'on en dise n'est pas un
choix là noureev c'est à dire
qu'effectivement les grandes stars de la
gamme herriot peuvent choisir l'ouest si
je vais le dire mais les autres tous les
élèves hrvoje pouvoir restaurer prendre
un cas d'école actuellement à la
fondation en béton depuis cinq mois et
l'exposition morozov elle range of
patrimoine
génie de l'intelligence russe qui a
acheté et bâtisses et toutes ces choses
là alors que on les connaissait pas qui
les ont gardés pendant la période
stalinienne cacher puis finalement
ressorti mais très bien mais une
exposition comme celle là vous n'obtenez
pas si vous n'avez pas des discussions
quasiment deux chefs d'état en chef
d'état entre le patron de 8 ans et
vladimir poutine alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux éditions
on voit tout de suite ont fermé
soumission renvoie les tableaux je pense
que ce soit dur de se faire parce que je
pense cela je suis assez d'accord
les oeuvres les est renvoyé au 3 avril
regardez les oeuvres contre les lois ça
mais moi si j'avais été encore aux
affaires ou temps où ça m'était jamais
arrivé j'aurais renvoyer les mois tout
de suite c'est à dire vous auriez
interrompu son exposition
à cette exposition dont qui est
exactement le cas le câble typique de
d'un élément patrimonial incontestable
magnifique fait courir tout le monde et
qui sert en vérité deux sous-marins de
la propagande quotidienne puisque ça ne
prenne à car pas en même temps la
fondation vuitton est privé donc je ne
sais pas quand vous par we met d'accord
m'a fait les plombiers s'est logée sur
de petits
dans le monde ses raids pour toujours
privés d ordre de marie après
maintiennent quoi par exemple dont les
musées sont brûlés par les russes dont
il ya aussi le musée de rap qu'il ya
plein de patrimoine architectural qui
est détruit dans ce temps réel comme
quand on parle voilà c'est ça que je
pense quand on discute et ses oeuvres le
vrai je rejoins nous rejoignent et
frédéric mais qu'est ce que c'est leur
être envoyée toutes les
explosions a dû être arrêté oui il lui
fallait marquer le coup alors bon c'est
une entreprise privée sous bernard
arnault pour ne pas le citer j'ai
l'habitude et je ne les a jamais de bon
je veux pas faire d'un tweet hyper sonné
mais je ne vais pas citer mais chez le
site est un cas d'école classique qui
fait que en vérité et bien c'est pas
possible de présenter malgré son immense
qualité une exposition qui n'aurait pas
eu lieu sans l'accord l'appui de la
dîmière donc ça veut dire on fait passer
le combat avant l'art c'est ça que ça
veut dire non on fait passer le pont ont
fait passer je suis désolé
on fait passer le respect de la culture
avant son utilisation et son
détournement faut faire passer le combat
avant l'arc votre réaction luba
jurgenson non mais l'art peut-être aussi
le lieu du combat et donc c'est ça qu'il
faut retenir et je pense qu'il faut
surtout pas laisser à poutine le
territoire de l'art et de la culture il
faut pas qu'on se dise
tchaikovsky et poutine c'est la même
chose oui donc c'est extrêmement
important d'arracher aussi la culture à
à ce pouvoir qu'il a usurpé et qui qui
s'en sert donc mais c'est toute la
difficulté pour revenir à mon exemple on
parle effectivement des grandes stars du
bolchoï qui
doit faire ce choix n'est pas choisie
comme poutine c'est la même personne
d'ailleurs la glycine et tenter un yuke
rennes 7e voilà les amis ukrainiens de
tchaïkovski qu'il a eu cette idée
bombardé et tous les artistes modestes
ou les gens qui travaillent les gens qui
font la musique et les milliers milliers
de gens qui sont en russie aujourd'hui
et qui certainement sont plus conscients
parce que ils ont vu plus de choses que
les gens qui vivent à novossibirsk par
exemple même si je pense qu'il ya à
nouveau cyber qui est aussi un grand
théâtre tous ces gens là on peut pas les
punir non plus
je pense que l'art est peut être tout à
fait une arme et je pense que aussi bien
vite il faut laisser ceux qui veulent
apprendre qu'ils n'ont pas peur je pense
qu'il faut laisser le faire il se battre
comme ils peuvent contre la russie
d'aujourd'hui pour la russie de demande
pour le cren un premier lieu et je pense
que beaucoup d'artistes réfugiés qu'ils
soient écrits en russe bombe se battre
pour la même chose pour dakar pour
justement cette question est-ce que ça a
vraiment un impact ce boycott culturel
ou en tout cas effectivement cette pause
dont vous parlez est ce que ça a un
impact ce qu'on en a comme l'impression
que l'idée est ce que l'impact est d
abord psychologique est ce que d'idées
c'est vraiment d'isoler toute la culture
rue c'est sale des lampes ex l'impact
s'est toujours c'est mettre la pression
en ce moment voilà c'est ça l'impact
c'est le moment où on fait attention à
ce que ce ce qui arrive est donc on est
vraiment très reconnaissants par toutes
les communautés qui nous est solidaire
en ce moment est-ce que ce qu'on
aimerait vraiment proposé pour le monde
dont 10 découvrir le cren découvrir le
cinéma ukrainien
la pointure crânienne les traduire les
auteurs craignent un faire les chairs du
coup les gens puissent apprendre la
culture écrit la langue créole parce que
ça c'est sûr on acte de quoi proposer on
a les danseurs des ballets on a on a de
tout c'est juste que c'était toujours
malheureusement parle par la rhétorique
russe s'est toujours mis quelque part un
arrière ce qui est donc là on en fait
c'est une culture par une autre non non
non pas du tout je ne suis pas sage et
oui on présente la culture ukrainien
donc essayer de choper par les
noms nagy on va bien bien bien sûr rang
on a sans doute une très grande
ignorance en france par pas ma voisine
de la culture ukrainienne
parce qu'elle a été en quelque sorte
étouffé par l'idée de la culture
soviétique et ensuite par là tout
omnipuissance de vladimir poutine on est
arrivé il y avait dans le métro quand il
ya pas longtemps il y avait des affiches
pour les ballet de kiev etc mais c'était
en fait perçu quasiment comme déjà une
truc poutinien s'était pas il y avait le
ballet de kiev que mam ou est-ce que
c'est elle balaye kiev ou pas été qui
dansaient la kill the pros je ne sais
pas en tout cas la tête la connaissance
de la culture ukrainienne elle est
faible il ya eu de grands écrivains et
des poètes mm vous avez absolument
raison mais il n'est pas question de
retranchés des éléments de la culture
russe pour les remplacer par des
ukrainiens il est question d'ajouter
d'enrichir voilà moi c'est ce que je
pense by organe n'a pas réfléchi sur la
sur le colonialisme russe à côté des
autres colonialisme et le moment est
sans doute venu de n'ouvrir a vraiment
cette page aussi dans la recharge b et
le cette dimension coloniale de la
culture russe on doit aussi la
travailler nous il faut faire une
introspection absolument il faut y
réfléchir
oui j'ai nagé sur les colonials mais on
les a pas forcément effacé pour ton les
années 30 vous êtes grands spécialistes
mais on se souvient combien d'artistes
étaient détruits étaient massacrés
techniquement elle était détruit donc la
question pour nous c'est de ne pas
répéter ça parce que on voit vous avez
vu ce de l'article des serviteurs voilà
c'est que ce monsieur qui a conseillé de
poutine ses médias officiels russes où
ils ont noir sur blanc le plan des
destructions d'ukraine y compris la
culture donc pour nous c'est pour nous
faire maintenant en sorte que la culture
ukrainienne existe qu'elle est mise en
valeur qu'elle est mise en lumière
ce matin moi j'ai l'impression que l'on
parle de colonisation effectivement
poutine et pas seulement lui deux autres
dirigeants avant lui regardez le cren
combien sur deux colonies un peu comme
la france avec l'algérie à une époque
d'ailleurs pendant la guerre d'algérie
je sais pas s'il y avait des appels au
boycott de l'art français
nicole bon voilà je ne pense pas que
c'était une méthode qui est utilisée
avant mais c'est vrai que il faut
considérer que le cren a été pendant
très longtemps
colonisée par là aussi qu'on ne sait pas
ou si poutine dans le monde au 20e
siècle et que sa libération pas
forcément permettra de allart craignant
d'arriver en europe en
quantité beaucoup plus grande beaucoup
plus libre parce que voilà c'est un pays
qui s'est libérée qui compte je pense
projet un mot de conclusion parce qu'on
a un terme et problème c'est que on
parle d'après là mais on sait pas ce
qu'est après parce que c'est pas parce
que les armées russes à évacuer les
alentours de kiev en laissant la mort et
l'horreur derrière elle que c'est fini
pas du tout finie donc la presle après
c'est dans longtemps 1 donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut c'est penser par contre
opposé pas donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
rester très vigilant sur tous les points
que nous avons abordé aujourd'hui pour
essayer d'avoir des attitudes
raisonnable et mesurée et morale c'est
difficile merci beaucoup en tout cas ça
sera une autre conclusion remercie
beaucoup frédéric mitterrand d'avoir été
avec nous merci à yves gagné à galperine
merci à vous irene cara merci loubat
joergensen merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et vous reste avec nous sur
france 24